hello my name is susanna i'm bachelor in
computer science from the university of
london
today i'm presenting my research project
developed during the research fellowship
program at buying biotech
the title of the research is
identification of novel therapeutic
targets in soyuz skin an isoform
approach psoriasis is an autoimmune
disease mainly characterized by
sustaining skin inflammation abnormal
keratinocyte proliferation and
differentiation decreased apoptosis
vascular abnormalities and thermal
inflammatory infiltrates histology
exchanges in psoriatic skin include
parakeratosis and an increased number of
vascular structures
the patients usually present lesions in
portions of the skin but in extreme and
usually life-threatening cases 100
percent of the skin could be involved
this characteristic allows to compare
election and non-legend skin from the
same psoriatic patient
although the skin profile is the
hallmark of the disease there is
evidence of its systemic impact and
increased risk of developing other
diseases like cardiometabolic disease or
chronic kidney disease
ngs transcriptomic psoriasis dataset
have been analyzed at the gene level and
have unveiled relevant inflammatory
pathways but current treatments
modulating the immune response have
important side effects and they do not
cure
some widely used thoracic drugs include
dnf alpha inhibitors that can
effectively clear lessons that may
present safety concerns like increased
service infection risk
since psoriasis is a chronic disease
patients usually require long-term
treatments which could increase the risk
of presenting side effects
hence alternative charges for treatments
are required either to reduce the side
effects or support a cure
the objective of this study is to
identify social new treatment targets
from an isoform level perspective
this project used this public rna
sequence data set which originally
contains
147 samples of five conditions
it includes atopic dramatic patients
psoriasis patients and healthy controls
for the purposes of this study only
samples from control and psoriasis
patients were selected the skin
transcriptase of 45 subjects were
analyzed at the isoform lab
from the transcriptomic pair reads
expression isophone levels were
generated by running the pipeline shown
at the top left of this slide
this pipeline generated two main output
expression levels files for isoforms an
fekm table and a raw read counts table
but tables were split into three groups
for 40 comparison
here are the groups selected which
corresponds to
the
healthy control versus the psoriatic
null lesion healthy control versus the
psoriatic lesion and
psoriasis non-lesion versus psoriatic
relation
the output table containing fpkm
recounts isoform expression levels
underwent log transformation and
quantile normalization with a threshold
of 5.
this table was used to conduct pci
exploratory analysis and remove outliers
from the samples
in this slide the resulting pci plots
after removing outliers are shown at the
bottom and a clear separation between
conditions can be observed
once outliers were identified the
respective samples were also removed
from the three tables containing gravity
cans which were previously prepared by
removing genes we've assumed
less than or equal to five across of all
samples
each prepared types of and private
counts expression table corresponding to
each of the three groups was uploaded
for differential expression analysis at
this step hr was used with the
parameters log file change less to minus
1.5
b value
less than 0.01
and false discovery rate less than 0.05
for the pairs of compare conditions h
are identified
for healthy versus non-election a total
of 107
transcripts
from and
49 new transcripts novel isoforms
the second group called the versus
lesson
identified
4
819
total transcripts and for the third
group it
identified a total of
2721 transcripts
the top 10 unregulated and upregulated
isoforms were selected for each group
and the resulting sets were compared
between conditions to extract the
markers of psoriatic skin and the
markers of lesion psoriatic skin
this slide presents the matched isoforms
among the differentially expressed
isoforms the nobel sequence
corresponding to vitamin b was further
analyzed
this isoform was selected because its
respective chief is not identified at
gene level studies and the product of
the gene influences molecules and
mechanisms related to psoriasis for
example mmp9 vegfa
cell proliferation apoptosis risk
pathway and angiogenesis
here are shown the other identified
stock
down regulated or upregulated isoforms
some of them are already identified
as differential expressed at the gene
level
to select the nearest node transcripts
the novel sequence was used for multiple
sequence alignment this figure shows the
novel isoform aligned against the 28
known isoforms available at its summer
the sequence of the novel trans was
further compared against the nearest
identified isoforms which are the
canonical sequence the isoform and the
iso49 and their coding sequences
allow us to predict that the translated
protein of the new sequences
may be the same that the filament b
isoform aches
the following figure represents the
differences in the sequences during the
comparison
vitamin b
a isoform egg has an extra amino acid
sequence when compared to the canonical
one but it maintains the associated
biological processes the novel
transcript has that insertion coding for
the extra amino acid sequence but also
contains non-translated nucleotide
sequences present in the canonical
sequence and in the isoform 9.
considering the predicted translated
protein the deficiency of the novel
identified isoform is also expected to
decrease apoptosis increased
self-proliferation increased cell
inflation mediated by brass error and
leads to higher mmp9 and befa
all of them are characteristics of
psoriatic relation skin
the
deficiencies of the
vitamin b
are existed here
many of them match the psoriatic
relations profile skin
and here are the
relation of sodium molecules
with psoriasis
so within this context filament b might
represent a potential target for future
treatments and it might provide an
alternative option for regulating mmp9
vegfa
and class her pathways
unlike mmp inhibitors philamine b will
not block other mmps so this could
decrease side effects at the same time
the activity
of v e gfi could be regulated
so it could lead to reduced formation of
capillary structures
of genes graph 14 s 100 a7 a dcn 1 sp
rr2f and
def4a were found to be representative of
the psoriatic skin profile
the first ones
have been found to be differentially
expressed in psoriasis at the gene level
all of them also uprobulated
however when comparing psoriasis lesion
versus the control
dcn1 expressed three differentially
expressed isoforms whereas for
non-rational versus healthy controls
there was only one differentially
expressed isoforms
hence
one isoform which corresponds to the
canonical sequence
can be an indicator of psoriatic skin in
general while the other two dcn1
isoforms which are not translated into
protein might be relevant in flare ups
on the contrary graph 14 is not
identified to be differentially
expressed at the gene level and this
novel transcript found in this studies
predicted to produce the same protein as
the canonical sequence
isoforms of genes
a e a
f 4 a 2 philamine b
c a c and a 1 h cast add 3 and
r e r 1 are proposed to be indicators of
lesion psoriatic skin
and only cacna1h
is already known to be differentially
downregulated at the gene level
the downregulated isoforms of caste are
taught to be involved in what's called
protein degradation in living tissue
furthermore
gust reduces levels of protein scalping
a protein that presents increased levels
in arthritis rheumatoid and other
optimum disease
for add3 one of the three differentially
expressed isoforms is expected to impact
the cytoskeleton organization while
another transcript
does not code for a protein and the
other one represents a novel one
another transcript of filament b was
found whose translated protein is
predicted to be the same as uniprot
identifier for the isoform 8.
its down regulation is expected to
increase the activity of mmp9 and
vegfa
and the probably federation rates of
keratinocytes
the expression and activity of mmp9 and
vegefa are directly proportional to the
severity of the psoriatic relations and
its upregulation can produce
psoriatic-like lesions in models
however current drugs trageding them
have severe side effects since both
molecules can be regulated by vitamin b
this study proposes that filament b
supplementation or treatments aiming to
upregulate this gene could be effective
in flare-ups credence
i would like to thank to dr prager
vendra and mr ilia broski for mentoring
this project and also
thank you for sonalika ray for all the
support and all the theme from find
biotech and omislogic
thank you so much